hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to lurking now lurking is a
game that's based on sound so the reason
why I'm speaking softly is because the
game is based on echolocation so in this
initial room you can see everything but
if you move out of it
you'll see what happens everything is
based on sound and actually the game
itself is based on my microphone so the
noises that I make from speaking are
able to help me see the world around me
because it's calibrated to my microphone
but but also my voice can lead the
enemies to my location so I can create
sounds and by walking around and
pressing buttons to create sound or I
could just speak loudly and it would
actually create sounds in the world here
so I'm going to try to not do that
because that would probably lead to me
dying so we're gonna be very cautious
about this hundred dollars just hit me
finally moving into human styles and
gives us were key to be gracious
achievement munis on server and everyone
will finally know mine yet the operation
on this subject zero one will commence
in about hours time subject years in
optimal conditions it regards to the
ports from the assistance I would like
to go on record to say that I observe no
abnormal behavior
subjects at all okay cool dude
now I don't know exactly what the
neuroscience experiment that he is and
also my microphone is we're very
sensitive right now so if I scream it's
not going to be pleasant for anyone and
it'll blow out the microphone at you all
will not be happy so I'm going to
control my voice as best as possible
this is a horror game in case you guys
couldn't handle whoa hi buddy what do I
do about hello hi how are you okay
expecting to wake up any moment
incipient however the dead have somehow
managed to escape the confines and we
need to find them we try to recapture
them now and some idiot must have left
the cage door open I don't know stupid
stupid doctor crystal
okay cool so about the lab rats I don't
really care about that because there's
this guy on the other side of the glass
is he gonna be okay he's gone now okay
good so this is going to be a very
different let's play from what I
normally do because I just have to be so
careful about what I say and when I say
it now I wanted to play this game a long
time ago it was actually released quite
a ways into the past but it always broke
for me
haha Oh God uh I thought it was like in
a cage or something I knew that it was
gonna uh man I knew that it was gonna
make noise when I go on the glass oh man
where am I now
okay let's try that again although it
was terrifying everyone be very quiet
there
okay fine everything's fine everything
is fine everything is totally fine
nothing bad is gonna I don't want to run
why would I run I don't want to run that
would be a terrible decision I really
don't think he was supposed to be able
to get me it just happened to be like a
bug that I got too close to the door or
the wall over there that he was able to
get me okay so everything is fine
everything is totally fine everything is
gonna be okay are you guys properly
soothed wait a minute was husband oh
that's right this was all broken down
okay man even the enemy's whisper teeth
it's so creepy okay so I think I'm
relatively okay so long as I don't speak
loudly everything's gonna be just fine
I also saw when I was downloading this
game that there was a spiritual
successor in the works and that means
that there'll be another game in this
style because this is a really really
cool concept even though it does demand
that the player have a microphone well I
guess you know most people don't
most people don't talk to themselves so
someone's not having a fun time on that
toilet why do I want to see why do I
want to go here hi how are you doing are
you okay
you don't have a red aura about you so
I'm assuming that you're gonna be okay
is everything all right I'm just gonna
carry on though doesn't seem like he's
gonna bother me so it was a path up a
walkway that I saw that I need to go up
that's supposedly
I know that I don't need to whisper all
the time but I got my microphone set to
a very specific sensitivity right now
and I don't want to ruin that he's very
finicky not many people know the
intricate oh boy
oh I mean I always say that sound is so
incredibly important - why are you doing
that you show them all right oh man it's
so intricate with a like a it feels
weird whispering from doing 2,800 videos
where I'm shouting at the top of my
lungs so the only thing I can compare to
is the cat therapy videos okay I don't
know what my objective is see that's the
thing about this game I actually don't
know what I'm supposed to do because if
I'm actually supposed to do something
then
this is so weird oh man I know it
wouldn't mean anything if I actually
didn't scream at that point kid is
already coming after me okay alright
then okay oh we're okay
everything is just Oh what are you doing
why are you doing that okay you're
making a lot of noise it's not that
so whatever procedure that these what if
a procedure that these guys did it
probably made all these subjects blind
and but able to see through echolocation
and I don't know why this work is
important but it's oh I didn't know I
didn't know okay how did I get to a
laundry room I don't know what's gonna
make these guys turn from good to bad so
I don't want to try to do anything
it's weird cuz my brain wants to say
Bowl like I normally do oh god ah it's
not cool oh that's so not cool I gotta
stop talking this is why I'm trying to
whisper I knew would come to a point
where I would oh yeah I forget the key
button actually that's makes shouting I
just came here oh that's so scary oh is
he just like standing at the bottom of
the stairs is there nothing I can do
about that that's so scary
okay well this professor doesn't seem to
be berry nice hey I'm a genius
I'm so smart I'm the smartest person I
know I'm so smart I'm so smart I'm so
smart I am smart now the smarty smarty
smart Oh what was that what is this
is it the outside world will I be able
to go home and see oh I need a keycard
oh god why am i wandering around a house
oh I am I am the greatest I'm sure you
are okay so I'm pretty sure there's
gotta be someone upstairs there has to
be it's the only thing that makes sense
I can get out of here
yeah
where are you show yourself your work I
don't know what you said yeah so you
everywhere they try to hide and I know
they are there I can see that one I can
see well that's not good
I didn't know what was gonna happen okay
so I just got to get around him oh why
does he eat me
am I good am i good am I good
did I won Oh God
that doesn't look fun I think I saw a
silhouette standing in the doorway Oh No
alright so that was lurking so alright
so that was an experimental survival
horror game and it was really really
cool I love the concept of this and I
love the fact that they're moving
forward with this idea so I hope you
guys enjoyed this video let me know if
you did because it is a unique and
interesting game and a different take on
horror than what I've seen in the past
so this was cool let me know what you
think and also check out the website to
look into what they're making in the
future down the road so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you
I think I get it all right let's see
what scot-free how's it just choose your
paint down